Hey everybody. Welcome to the podcast.
Very excited because my guest today is Mary Cain,
the Mary Cain.
The track and field athlete who by high school
had established herself as the fastest girl in a generation.
The Mary Cain who at 17
became the youngest American ever
to make a world championship track and field team.
The Mary Cain for whom
Olympic glory seemed a foregone conclusion,
until that is, she joined Nike's elite Oregon Project
under Alberto Salazar.
Within that culture, her body ultimately collapsed,
her running career behind it.
And for a couple of years thereafter,
she just kind of disappeared,
until November of 2019 that is when Mary broke her silence
on what happened and why,
telling her story by way of a video op-ed
in "The New York Times" entitled,
"I Was the Fastest Girl in America, Until I Joined Nike".
That video went crazy viral.
It resulted in a groundswell of global support for Mary,
and opened the door to a broader ongoing conversation
around the toxicity that pervades female athletics,
and the means by which we can construct a better future
for women and girls in sports.
Not content to merely tell her story
or just get back to running, but to actually do something,
make a real difference,
Mary just announced the launch of Atalanta,
a New York City based elite running team
and community nonprofit.
It's an endeavor that she leads as CEO,
with the dual mission of promoting running community,
inclusivity and diversity,
and rewriting the rule book on
professional women's athletics.
Today, we get into all of it.
Her story is powerful.
This one is kind of a wild, emotional ride,
and I'm really proud to help share it.
So thanks for watching.
Hit that subscribe button, and here we go.
This is me, Rich Roll by the way, and Mary Cain.
(light melodic music)
So nice to meet you.
Sorry you got the wrong address and got a little bit lost,
but you're here-
Oh, yeah.
I've been waiting for this for a long time.
I've been texting all our mutual friends
telling them how excited I am to meet you.
So thanks for doing this.
Yeah. Absolutely.
I mean, I'm just excited to be able to travel to LA.
This has been such a fun little long weekend.
Is it your first time traveling since the whole shebang?
About a month ago, I had traveled to Park City,
and that had been one of those trips that were canceled,
and you had to book within a year,
and all of a sudden April was rolling around and we're like,
"I guess we're still going."
So that was my first time on a plane. So this was my second.
Right. What was the vibe?
I dunno. I felt it was good
in that everybody's wearing their masks,
everybody seemed to be taking all the rules seriously.
And I was on a Delta flight,
so we were as spaced as we almost could be.
So yeah, I found if anything,
it felt pretty safe and that adds to the excitement maybe.
And what's the vibe in New York?
Does it feel it's coming back,
or this whole idea that New York City is dead.
New York City is not dead.
That is,
oh man, if you guys follow the real estate market
in New York City-
It's crazy, right? Everybody's going bananas.
I think New York is going to have this crazy Renaissance-
Oh 100%.
Maybe not right away,
but in the next year.
Mary Wittenberg is like, "This is the 1970s,
and we're gonna have this big Renaissance
of cultural influence now, again,
and just 50 years later,
where you go through a really tough time and it resurges."
And I think you see that even in the recent announcements
about you don't have to wear masks outside anymore,
and certain things shifting.
You all of a sudden feel this energy of like,
"Oh, I wanna come back,"
and I think even people who left
are starting to get a little antsy of like,
"What am I gonna miss out on?
Maybe I need to come back."
Well, when summer hits
and you get those nice warm nights in New York,
I think it's gonna be like the summer of love.
Oh yeah, I mean, I'm right near Central Park too,
so I probably have a timed skewed view
of how many people are out and about,
but gosh, if I go for my evening run and it's 60 degrees,
I can barely get around the reservoir some days
'cause you're just like,
"Everybody wants to be out right now."
Right, and it's cool, it's exciting funnily, right?
Oh, and its fun even from the running perspective
of yes, you have that moment where you're hurdling a kid
in Central Park and you're like,
"This maybe could have been better,"
but in general, the more people are out,
the more energy that is, and then you feed off it.
Yeah, you feel it, you get that surge of vitality
that only New York can deliver.
Yes, absolutely 'cause it's just so dense, and so diverse,
and there's so many people
kind of following their own dreams and passions,
and as a result,
I just feel like there's inspiration everywhere you turn.
Yeah, you don't get that here,
that's why I feel I have to visit a couple of times a year
to get that feeling,
and then come back renewed and exhausted.
Yeah, fair.
I mean, the thing I will say,
and I'm born and raised in the New York City area,
I grew up in the suburbs right outside of the city,
and so I've probably always had a bit of a bias view,
but nowhere else in the country is a city.
We are the only place that is truly an urban environment.
There's no sprawl in the same way that we have suburbs,
but the actual density of each block is just,
like maybe Chicago could hold their own,
but sometimes even my friends and coworkers in Boston
will be kind of comparing Boston to New York and I'm like,
"oh,-"
That's cute.
"You're a small town."
Well, the thing about,
I mean, New York City is my favorite place to go running.
Even though I love the trails, and the nature,
and all of that, when you go running in New York City,
every time you go outside your door, it's an adventure,
and you're gonna see all kinds of stuff,
and sometimes I just I love the park, I like Riverside,
I like all the typical places that you run.
But sometimes I to just run the streets
and not have any agenda about which way I'm gonna turn,
just based on the lights or whatever,
and just go down random streets and just take it all in.
And there's so much stimuli everywhere you look
that you lose track of how long you've been running,
and I don't know, I just love it.
Oh, I completely agree.
I've always said that New York City is the best
running city in the world.
And when I use the word city there,
I'll give other places a chance to claim city hood.
That's so kind of you,
you provincial New Yorker.
I have to be generous.
Now you're getting snobby, careful.
Yeah, exactly.
But I think for me, it's one, the fact that it's the only,
it's one of the only places in the world
where there's such a vibrant amateur set up,
where there's true teams, and there's competitions weekly,
and we have New York road runners there who can help put on
just like races week after week after week.
And I think since there's such a
organized ability to participate in sports,
post collegiately, particularly running,
it just creates this dynamic to where
you never are in Central Park alone.
It doesn't matter what time it is.
If it's 5:00 a.m. I'm shocked
by the number of people who will be out in giant groups
having way too much fun, even though it's 5:00 a.m.
and I'm not normally a 5:00 a.m. runner,
but the times that has happened,
I'm really I think carried by that energy.
Yeah, the running culture is just interwoven
with the urban culture of New York.
And it's crazy when you go into the park
and you see people running and it's like,
"Wow, these are real runner."
You're like, "That guy's legit."
Some dude add you're like,
"I don't know what he's training for,
but whoever's racing against that guy I feel sorry for."
True elites everywhere you go.
And everybody else at the same time
like it's kind of a cool, beautiful thing.
Yeah, and I think that's what's exciting
about New York too,
where it spans kind of from the highest end professionals
to people who are just starting running.
And I don't feel there's almost this setup
where it's like in order to join a team,
you have to have had X, Y, and Z standards.
If anything, it's like so many of the groups
are catering more to this community environment,
and just being inclusive,
and welcoming people who maybe this is their first time
ever stepping out to go for a run.
And to me that's just important because I think elsewhere,
it can become maybe more intimidating to join a team
because you only run if you're this quote unquote "Runner,"
which I hate when people say that,
I'm like, "If you run, you're a runner.
There's no threshold, I'm not asking for your splits."
And I think in New York we kind of have that mindset
of if you run, you're a runner,
and elsewhere it can get a little bit more
maybe people kind of hedge, and they're like,
"Ah, maybe not good enough to be on that team,
they seem pretty serious, so I'm not gonna join something."
That intimidation, right?
Well spoken like a true community manager.
What's your title a Tracksmith, something like that,
Vice President of Community or something?
Yeah, I'm the New York City Community Manager.
That's so funny, right? You have a job title.
I know
I actually, well, it's kind of crazy.
I have three job titles now.
New York City Community Manager for Tracksmith,
I'm a Virtual Coach Specialist to New York Road Runners
where I work part time.
And now I'm CEO of an organization I'm starting,
Atalanta New York.
Atalanta,
we're gonna talk about that.
Before we do that though,
I went running with our mutual BFF,
Alexi Pappas, the other day.
And it's funny, I didn't really think about
whether you guys were friends or not.
I guess I just assumed,
"Oh yeah, they must know each other,"
but I didn't realize the depth of your friendship,
and how far back it goes
until I read that beautiful "Runner's World" article,
which is amazing, everybody should check that out,
I'll link it up in the show notes.
You guys go way back.
And we're of course chatting,
and she's telling me about her movie and all kinds of stuff,
and then she, but she knew that you were coming on the show,
which I was like, "Oh, cool you know that?"
And she's just telling me a little bit.
I was like, "What should I ask her?
What should we talk about?"
And she was like, "Well, everybody
obviously wants to know about the thing, right?"
Which we're gonna have to talk about
because this isn't an exclusively running oriented podcast,
so there's gonna be people who don't know that story.
But also this sense of you not wanting to,
understanding people wanna hear that story,
but not wanting to dwell on the past,
and really being more focused on
all the great things that you're doing now
that you're doing so well.
And I was like, "Cool."
And after our run and Alexi texted me
'cause she had additional thoughts.
Of course she always has.
Right of course.
And she said, "Mary is doing great,
but there's always grieving to do.
And I think she's doing a phenomenal job
of observing and allowing that grief
while also growing up and crafting a life she wants
before her own eyes, so it's both.
She's great, and she knows she has all that inside."
That's amazing.
Alexi just has a way with words that I feel
the number of times after we've had
a 90 minute conversation over the phone,
and we say our goodbyes,
five minutes later, she ends up sending a paragraph
that just literally makes me tear up
about how much our friendship means to her,
or just some inspirational thing based on
a different topic that we had talked about
over the course of the conversation.
And I always feel my reply is probably not as eloquent.
But she knows.
Well, she always said
she was gonna go get her PhD in poetry,
and her book,
I mean, not everybody can write a book like that,
it's quite something.
It was beautiful.
I mean, I was one of the first people who got to read it,
and I think I finished it in two days,
and I just the whole time would be texting her stuff.
And some of the stories,
even though we are very good friends, I didn't know,
and a lot of it was on that personal level for her
where many people who were very close to her
didn't have that full picture.
And being able to
get to be one of the first people to see that,
and experience that, and then talk to her about it
felt very special.
And conversely, she was not aware
of all the things that you were going through at the time.
It's that thing where you're in that pain,
and you silo yourself off even from your closest friend
'cause you guys were close back then,
but neither of you were really communicating with each other
on that deeper level about what you were enduring privately.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think in many ways
the reason we are both very vocal now about mental health,
depression, and the need to talk about it,
and the need to seek help, and lean on other people
is because we reflect on our own journeys,
which have shockingly overlapped,
even on a year to year it's like,
"Wow, 2016, what happened in that year?"
And as you kind of look,
I think as we look back, there's this ability to see
maybe if we could've, should've, would've
and leaned on each other,
things would have gone a little differently.
And that's not to say
you can talk yourself out of depression,
that's not to say
you can talk yourself out of a mental health struggle,
but at least being able to know
somebody else is going through it,
and maybe working together to find the resources
to get us help, could have saved us both sooner.
And knowing that makes me always think
how can I help somebody else take that step earlier?
Yeah.
Well, I think Alexi writing her book
and you sharing your story
in the way that you have been doing is the path forward
because that gives other people the comfort,
and the empowerment required to share something that
privately they feel maybe they can't, right?
I know you're a big Brené Brown fan.
Yes.
And she's all about that
can you summon the courage to be vulnerable on that level?
Yeah, and I think for me it's always come back to,
and I just say this in that as honest way as I can that
for me, it always was like,
"Yes, this is gonna help me in my own healing journey,
completely.
If I share, then it's kind of like putting,"
sometimes putting words out there can create truth
in a way that thoughts can't quite do and,
it's the same reason why during a workout
sometimes you have to verbalize, "I got this,"
just feel that extra energy.
And so that kind of maybe selfish reason
is part of the reason I shared my story,
but so much more so it was,
it's scary to realize that so many mental health injuries,
as Alexi would call them,
are something that even if you have it,
you can't recognize in the same way.
And I think physical injuries, especially as runners,
we can relate to this,
who hasn't run through an injury
for two weeks longer than they should have
'cause they convinced themselves it was something else,
or something they could work through,
or et cetera, et cetera,
but issues that relate to mental health,
I feel like since you can't physically see it,
since you can't get that MRI diagnosis,
and even since it's harder to find medical professionals
who are always going to really know
how to help you as an individual,
I think it's just harder
to sometimes recognize what you're actually going through.
And so, the big reason that I came forward,
and I know the big reason that Alexi is sharing her story,
is because if it can help one other person
put a name to what their experience is,
then the ability for them to seek help is so much higher.
And I know for me personally
I always kind of explain to people that
I knew in 2016 that I had forms of disordered eating,
but I didn't know why,
I didn't know what that kind of deeper,
darker depression was underneath
that was predisposing me to have these tendencies.
And it wasn't until I was able to actually realize that
emotional abuse by the hands of a coach
was what was always holding me back from truly
both getting the help that I needed,
but also knowing how to get the help that I needed.
It just made all those years before not pointless,
but not as successful as they could have been,
fruitful, and positive, and all those great things.
And instead it wasn't until 2019,
really around the time that I was sharing in the story,
that I was suddenly able to really get help.
Well, you can point,
you can kind of identify a couple primary reasons for that.
I mean, first of all there was,
of course there are women who have spoken publicly
about RED-S, and disordered eating in sport,
and all that all the like,
but perhaps not on the scale
with which your story seemed to connect.
I mean, it so crazy viral when the video was published.
And I wanna talk about that, but at the same time,
from a systemic point of view, you're on this team that
on paper look like everything was dialed in,
and all the support that any professional athlete
at the elite level, whatever need to succeed,
including quote unquote,
"Performance psychologists and nutritionists,"
that turned out weren't that at all, right?
So you can't really be too hard on yourself
because being as young as you were, and not knowing,
not being able to point two examples out in the world
that would help you kind of map out where you were at,
and not having the internal support
and the kind of situation, the dynamic that was at play
at the Oregon project at the time,
you were kind of left to fend for yourself with all of this.
Yeah, and I think now, today as I sit here,
I totally recognize that.
And I think the tough thing is,
and I think why in so many ways
the video went more viral than I had expected,
is because logically that's true,
but emotionally, it can take years for somebody to recognize
that they're not at fault.
And I think a lot of that is just societally
we have almost created this
horrible and toxic perspective that
all mental health is somehow a personal feeling,
and it kind of goes back to that Calvinistic
where you are is because of who you are in a way,
and I hate that thinking and it's horrible,
but I think that really kind of filters into
our society at large.
And as a result what's really difficult
for I think a lot of young people
is that when you're in these really toxic,
and horrible, and abusive situations,
as you're breaking down,
you start to see this quote unquote
"Truth in what they're saying"
because you are like,
"Yeah, I am super emotional.
I'm crying every single day.
Maybe I am the problem 'cause I'm the one crying,"
or, "Yes, I'm the one that they're telling is overweight.
So, that must be something I'm doing wrong."
And I think it's so easy to get therefore
into this really toxic self blame perspective,
and that's not to say there are things I look back
and I'm like,
"Oh, maybe, had I just know to be more confident,
or do this," and you always kick yourself in some ways,
but I think I've made peace with my past in a way that
being able to share publicly,
and almost develop this relationship
with thousands and millions of people
who were able to watch that
and kind of see themselves in my story
is both really tragic,
but also beautiful in that healing process
of knowing you're not alone.
Right.
We should probably sort of
establish the terrain that we're talking about
for people that are watching or listening
who aren't familiar with the trajectory of your story,
and how it became a viral moment.
So why don't we just spend a few minutes
talking about your background?
So you grow up outside of New York City, Bronxville.
You run in high school, you're crushing it,
you're breaking all these high school records,
it's absolutely insane winning high school titles.
And you essentially go pro right out of high school,
and start working with Alberto Salazar.
You move to Portland when you're 17, 16?
And that's where things start to get
a little bit janky, right?
So talk a little bit about
the lead up to moving to Portland,
and kind of the early days of working with Alberto
at the Nike Oregon Project.
Yeah, so I first met him the beginning of my junior year,
and I still lived in New York,
I was still a high school junior,
and we had this long distance relationship,
my junior and senior year,
during which I ended up qualifying
for the world championships at the end of my junior year,
signing a professional contract with Nike
my fall senior year,
and then going on to have a really incredible
senior year season.
And he's coaching you remotely at that point.
Yeah, and there are times where maybe
we were at the same meet together, or I travel out to,
like that summer that I competed on the world stage
I traveled out and was kind of like with their team
for maybe three or four weeks or something,
but it was always these kind of like little moments,
and it was always so much fun, right?
Because you have your coach
on the ground with me in New York, John Henwood,
who was kind of that buffer.
I had my parents there who were always that kind of buffer
between me and the team,
but everything sounded great,
and everything was going great in high school.
I was working with this,
now I have to say quote unquote, "Foreign psychologist,"
there was more positivity and everything was kind of like,
"Oh, this is fun."
And then I ended up after my indoor season senior year
developing a stress reaction in my shin.
And that was kind of a moment that things changed.
And I think truthfully,
and just at least how I kind of look back on it,
I think having a little bit of time off
my body started develop a little bit, right?
Nothing,
I didn't all of a sudden
gain 10 pounds or anything like that,
it wasn't something you could even necessarily visually see,
but physically I could tell
there was some sort of changes starting to happen
'cause I'm all of a sudden at the end of that high school,
going into college years,
this is when a lot of women start to develop.
And so, all of a sudden
weight started to become a conversation
in a way that in the past it hadn't really been,
and it would kind of start off small of being like,
"Oh, you're cross-training,
you have to be more conscientious of your weight,"
and it just kept building and building and building.
So by the time I was kind of in full swing
of the outdoor season,
I ended up coming in second at the US championships,
ran a 4:06, and was feeling really good and really positive.
But I kept being told that
I couldn't go to Europe that year to race
because I wasn't fit enough.
From Alberto.
Yes.
And it was this kind of like, "You're not fit,
you're not fit, you're not fit."
And I didn't,
I kind of was like,
"I kept sinking at the US championship, I think I'm unfit."
There's one person maybe a little bit more fit than me?
Literally, yes.
And so, I just didn't really get it,
and I ended up racing at the World Junior Championships.
And the day before the race
I was told to do two 100 meters all out.
And I was told to break 13 seconds for the 100.
And I ended up running 12:5 for both of them.
So I didn't think anything of it,
besides the fact that it's kind of weird
to do all out sprints the day before a race,
but after the race, Alberto, kind of that week, I was like,
"Hey, World Junior Champion, I'm second at USA,
let's dive in, let's go to Europe,
let's do what we did last year."
And that was when it finally became clear that
this fitness was about weight.
And it was because he told me that
the reason he had me do those 100s the day before
is that he wanted to have the talk the day before the race
that I was too heavy,
and he wanted me to do those 100s
'cause he didn't think I would be physically capable
of breaking 13 'cause he thought I was too big to do it.
But then you go 12:5,
and he didn't eat his lunch after that.
No, he still told me after the race that
even though I did that,
it's clear I'm not skinny enough to travel.
So of course I'm,
just graduated high school, literally moved out to Oregon
right after winning world juniors.
And rather than traveling to Europe,
we decide I'm gonna stay in Portland over the summer,
and I'm going to get fit, aka lose weight.
And there was kind of this idea that
if I lost one pound per week,
I could get down to 113 pounds to race at Fifth Ave,
and therefore I might be competitive.
And granted again, I came in second at USA, so I don't,
in retrospect, I should have just thought what the heck,
but this is hypothetically the best coach in the world.
Sure.
I mean, we're gonna dive deeper into the whole weight thing,
but on some level, when you tell that story,
it almost feels like a way in which
he can exert greater control.
Is it a control issue as much as it is a weight issue
because as long as he can Lord that over you,
then he can kind of be the puppeteer.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think we recognize that now,
in retrospect with other kind of behaviors that happened.
Like when I was in high school he communicated,
and all the team communicated a lot with my parents, right?
To be like after a good workout, there would be this like,
"Wow, Mary did awesome.
So cool. Congrats."
And it felt this really kind of like family, team dynamic,
and everything's just so positive.
As soon as I went out to Portland,
all communication with my parents stopped.
And what happened was that after world juniors,
as the dedicated athlete that I was who,
yes again, in retrospect
I was racing at this really high level,
but to me I'd been top 10 in the world,
I'm trying to be a world champion,
that's kind of like my end game.
So when somebody is telling me, "You are not fit enough,
'Well, yeah, I was second at USA's,
maybe that's top 20 in the world,
and I'm constantly pushing.'"
So I did what I was told
and I lost probably six to seven pounds
'cause I think I was about 120 at the time,
scaled down to 113.
And that was when disordered eating started.
And how was your performance that year?
Oh, it ended up pretty cool.
I mean, now I look back I'm like, "It wasn't that bad,"
but it was horrible compared to the years before.
But what happened was after Fifth Ave,
I didn't race that well, I came in eighth,
and I didn't look good.
My parents saw me 'cause we were back in New York,
and truthfully they had felt a little distanced from me
and from the program,
and it was kind of this weird last two months
of being a little bit ghosted.
And my mom saw me and was just like,
"You don't look good.
You look pale, dark circles under your eyes.
What's kind of going on?"'
And I admitted that I've been really working to lose weight.
I've been told I was too heavy to travel.
And my parents naturally got really upset about that
because they're like, "What are you even talking about?
You raced great.
Why is that a conversation?"
And a phone call was had with the,
I'll call him high-performance coach on the team,
and the coach-
Right this person
sort of held himself to be a psychologist,
but it turns out he was not indeed a psychologist.
Yes, exactly, and I thought he was a medical professional
and therefore treated our conversations as such.
But I afterwards got in big trouble for telling my parents
about my struggles with weight and everything.
And I got this big lecture,
which continued throughout that year,
where if I ever kind of like maybe told my parents something
that I was uncomfortable with,
or whether it was about taking birth control,
or an inhaler, or a thyroid medication, or whatever it was,
if I told them that then I would get yelled at
because I had to be an adult, I had to be a professional,
you can't go crying to your parents, all this sort of stuff.
And as an 18 year old who's at college, most freshmen.
Yeah, that's great.
I mean, you're 18 years old,
that's a crazy control thing, right?
"You're 18 years old,
how dare you tell your parents
what's going on in your life?"
And what's interesting about that is the fact that
Salazar's defense or rebuttal in the wake of
you coming out and sharing your story
is that he's claiming that
he was in constant communion with your parents
and talking to them about weight,
your dad's a doctor, right?
So is that just not true?
No.
I mean, it sounds like from your point of view
that it didn't happen at all.
So, when I was in high school again, they talked a lot.
There was a lot of this back and forth,
emailing, calling, super positive, right?
I move out to Portland, all of that ends.
And the only time my parents are hearing anything
is if it's coming from me.
I then get yelled at for telling them anything.
And then if they call and have this conversation,
it's kind of like,
"I'm a professional coach. I know what I'm doing."
And I think one thing about this
the whole situation as well as my dad is a doctor,
but if you meet any good doctor, right?
If something's not their area of expertise,
they're always gonna be like,
"No, go to somebody who is an OB-GYN, is an orthopedist,
et cetera, et cetera."
And I think there kind of was this feeling of like,
"This is a Nike.
This is a team that has a multi-million dollar budget.
Is paying people high amounts of money.
Is kind of presenting themselves as this
incredibly professional organization,
one of a kind situation."
And if they're being told that
I'm working with somebody for my mental health,
and and nutrition, and all that sort of stuff,
they're gonna assume that true.
Right, and that it's gonna be
somebody who's really good, right?
Exactly, yeah.
But this guy, this sports psychologist, Darren Treasure,
that was his name.
I read, I think this was in Chris Chavez's side piece,
that anything that any of the athletes shared with that guy
just ended up back with Alberto,
like it was this this kind of expectation of privacy
that in fact was not private at all,
it at all funneled back to Salazar,
again, him being a puppeteer,
and controlling the flow of information between everybody.
Yes and I came up in a household where there was a doctor,
and somebody who really prided themselves
on being a good doctor,
and being somebody who never overstepped the rules
or things like patient client privilege
is incredibly important.
And so, when you almost are exposed to that at a young age,
and then you're told somebody is a sports psychologist,
I know what that means,
and all the other athletes know what that mean.
And so, if they're telling something personal or private,
they're going to assume that
it's not gonna be told to somebody else,
let alone their competitor teammate,
or their coach who maybe they're talking about.
And over time, I really,
I think the thing I regret the most is that
there were moments where I realized what was happening
in that another athlete would be discussed with me
who I knew he worked with,
and in a way that was incredibly negative,
but rather than take that moment
and stepping back and saying,
"Hey, this is inappropriate.
He's hypothetically breaking laws
if he's truly a sports psychologist,
what is he doing to me?"
Instead in those moments, I was just like,
"I'm glad he's not talking about me, or my weight,
or saying something mean about me."
Yeah, I think the thing that people don't get,
or might miss in trying to understand that
this dynamic is that
when you're an athlete at the highest level,
and you're on this elite team,
there's a couple of things at play.
One of which is
everybody's trying to covet favor with the coach,
everybody wants to be the favorite.
You hear, Kara Goucher has spoken about this with Alberta,
and when you're in that catbird seat
and you are the favorite,
it doesn't matter what the coach is saying
about the other athletes because you're gonna protect that.
And just because you're all on the same team,
there isn't the esprit de corps that you would suspect
because everybody's vying
for a limited number of Olympic slots,
these may be your teammates
and you're training with them every day,
and on some level, some surface level,
you're mutually supportive,
but ultimately they're your competitors also.
So there's a cutthroat aspect of this.
So it's working at cross purposes
with the kind of unity that you would want
with the people you're showing up to train with every day.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think that's why personally
I've never named other athletes.
Even in stories that I've told
in which I'm referring to another teammate of mine
doing something negative, or being in the room or et cetera,
I don't name them because personally although I've never,
minus a couple of individuals,
I've never gotten really like a,
"Hey, I heard you," I'm sorry, moment,
I don't need that from them.
And even though I think their behavior was bad, and poor,
and the inability for people to stand up after the fact
and say like, "Yes, that was wrong,"
is something that I'm always gonna wonder,
it takes a lot of bravery to do that,
and it takes a lot of vulnerability to do that,
but it's my maybe ability to somewhat sympathize
is the reason that I don't.
I almost try to keep the athletes as out of this as I can.
Yeah, I mean,
and listen, we should point out that
in the wake of you sharing your story
with "The New York Times,"
so many people came out to support you,
and all these people that were on your team
have come out of the woodwork to say nice things about you,
and also express their regret at not having been
kind of more aware or supportive in the moment.
Yeah, and I think that's why it's like
both Cam Levins and Dathan Ritzenhein,
were my two athletes at the time,
who have since reached out to me,
and publicly said they witnessed,
or at least in the case of Cam,
witnessed some of this behavior,
is something that I always cry when I talk about that
'cause I think again,
for so many years when you think it's your fault,
having at least one person say they thought,
that's always the thing that kills me.
And I think it's just because
I know how brave it is to say I messed up,
I know how brave it is
to say I wish I did something different.
And there are people I wish that I had saved over the years,
and so, to have somebody come out and say
that really means a lot.
So, I always-
Especially
if and when they're still part of the Nike family,
there's a lot of stake, it's risky to do that and so,
yeah, that is something to be appreciated,
and it's very cool.
And in terms of you thinking perhaps
some of these situations alluded your gaze,
you're now in this incredible situation
where you can be this voice for change.
And I know you've taken that mantle seriously,
and we're gonna get into that.
But when I think about Alexi,
I see somebody who really appreciates
and understands the power of mentorship.
She's always seeking out mentors,
and she understands her responsibility and role as a mentor.
And on some level that's part of your friendship dynamic
because she's a little bit further down the path
and all of that.
And now because of your relationship with Alexi
and what you've gone through,
I feel like you really get that as well.
100%.
And I think for me as a very young athlete,
one thing that's always a little awkward,
and I'm sure everybody who's ever been kind of on that,
for lack of a better word phenom level,
you kind of expect everybody to welcome you with open arms
'cause you're like, "I'm 12, this is fun.
Everybody's gonna be my friend."
And the truth is you're often met with a lot of negativity,
especially within the competitive space.
And I get it, if you're a 30 year old competitor,
you don't really want this 18 year old beating you.
But I think kind of having felt like I was alone
for so long in sport,
and was able to find a friendship like Alexi's.
She was one of the first people who really
took me under their wing,
and shared advice, and shared stories,
and who didn't just
kind of look at me as purely a competitor,
or purely somebody to use for pacing or whatever.
And as a result now I'm very cognizant
of the younger generation,
and the people who are coming up,
and after a race,
they're gonna be the first people I'd be aligned over to
so that I can invite them to dinner, or hanging out with or,
just make them feel like they were a part of the event
in a way that matters.
And it's sad 'cause even to this day
I haven't been to too many races,
there've been a lot of injuries over the years.
But the ones that I am, it's like go over to somebody,
I'm like, "Why is nobody else doing this too?"
And I think it's because sport in so many ways has been,
at least on the professional side,
the number of times I'll listen to an interview
and an athlete will say like, "Well, sport is selfish,"
and I'm like, "I think that's a cop out.
I think it's selfish if you want it to be selfish."
If you wanna kind of not give back in some way,
then you can choose not to.
But if you wanna have a purpose kind of during your career,
and do something during it,
there's always gonna be opportunity to.
Yeah, well, I think people are wired in different ways.
There are certain competitors who feel like
that's the only path to greatness
is if they're completely focused on themselves.
Any athlete who's excelled with longevity though,
realizes that that's an unsustainable fuel source,
and ultimately leads to early retirement or burnout.
And the true greats at some point,
even if they had that mindset earlier,
realize that when you're living,
when you broaden the aperture on your life,
that actually your performance gets better.
I mean, Shalane talks about that quite a bit as well.
Like when she's having kids and all of that
and trying to juggle you think,
or Kerri Walsh Jennings, right?
She's married with kids and trying to juggle that,
and saying, "Oh, it actually helps me.
It makes me a better competitor."
But I think at the same time,
there's a systemic misalignment of incentives in that
the sponsorship ecosystem is set up
to financially reward you for your performance, right?
And this is something you're very active and upending,
but it's not just, "Hey, there's only a few slots
to make the world championship team or the Olympic team,"
it's that,
"My bank account is contingent upon me beating you,
and if I get beat by you,
my shoe sponsor may not renew my contract."
So you're living event to event and kind of in fear
of trying to protect your ability to put food on the table.
And so, that's gonna create a negative environment
in terms of how the athletes are
interacting with each other.
Absolutely.
And it's going to create the win at all costs culture,
and honestly predispose people to cheat.
And it's because I get it.
If that's your only financial opportunity,
and it's all about competition.
And I think the unfortunate thing too is
who gets a contract versus who doesn't?
Yes, it's all about performance,
but if you look the right way,
maybe we're gonna knock you a couple of extra dollars,
or if we just like the way you interview,
there's no real metric.
Even when you look at the disparity
between different people's contracts
because everything is NDA'd, and so nobody,
if you're in the sports world-
Yeah, there's no transparency about what they,
so the athletes don't know who's getting what.
Exactly, and some people might be open
and share with others,
and other times it's very tight lipped.
And the problem is you'll know one person's making
below minimum wage to compete at really the highest level,
and somebody else is doing incredibly well.
And even the incredibly well side it's just,
there's not a lot of money in track and field.
And I think when athletes aren't able
to really negotiate for themselves
when they're not even aware of
what's a good price to be negotiating,
it leaves just so much agency
out of the hands of the athletes.
I feel like the sponsorship approach
that a lot of these brands have historically taken
is really based on antiquated metrics.
The idea like,
"Oh, you have to make this team and go to the,
these are the events you're gonna show up at,
and if you get first, you get this, second, third,"
all of that, and that is dictating how much money you make
really doesn't make sense,
especially in a social media world.
What is the purpose of a company sponsoring an athlete,
it's to engender goodwill in the brand,
and hopefully encourage people out in the world
to purchase their products.
Well, how do you do that?
Well, winning races is just one way,
but in an era where
athletes are shouldering the responsibility
of communicating directly with audiences,
and developing their own trust with those people,
it's not,
where are you stand on the podium
no longer is really the most important thing.
It's who do people like?
Who do people trust?
That could be somebody who's not making any of these meets
or these competitions,
and somebody who no one's ever heard of
that has no audience and no interest
in communicating with the public in any way,
and wins, I don't know, the steeple chase
or something like that in some European race,
is that moving the needle in terms of the brand?
So it just doesn't,
it needs to be completely rethought bottom to top.
And that's why I love
kind of this relationship that you have with Tracksmith,
you're just basically a salaried employee and they're like,
"We love you, go do your thing,
and spread the love of running, and yeah, go do some races,
but where you end up in those races
really is not relevant to your paycheck."
Yeah, no, not at all,
and if anything,
I think they value my performance as an employee
more than an athlete.
I think if I was dropping the ball,
and missing all of my assignments,
I think we'd have real talking to,
even if I made the Olympic team tomorrow.
And I think that's incredibly important
because it's a way to value athletes
as more than just products.
It's a way for me to develop a career skill
that long-term is transferable into the open market
because as much as I love running
and as much as we all love sport,
everybody has a point where
they're going to have to move on to their next career,
and the truth is no runner is really getting set up for life
based on their salary.
It's not like we're in a professional sports league
where if you make it to 40,
you're retiring in a really great natural spot.
And as a result, there's kind of this
inability for most people in these traditional contracts
to develop those career skills in a way that's
as supportive as a relationship like Tracksmith that I have
where my training, my dreams as an athlete
are beyond supported.
And if one day I'm not dialing in until 10:30
'cause I had a little bit more
of an important workout in the morning,
so as a result I'm gonna be sending some emails at 7:00 p.m.
that's totally understood.
And that's encouraged, that's accepted,
and it's not something that I almost have to
combine two incompatible worlds.
And I think a lot of other athletes
who've had to kind of dive into the workforce
while sustaining their careers for that financial support,
it can be harder if you're just in a traditional company
that maybe doesn't understand why
you have to travel X amount of times to go to meets,
and kind of random parts of the country where they're like-
Yeah, and it's expensive.
Yeah, but if you look at other different kinds of sports
and certain legacy brands like in the climbing world,
in the mountaineering world,
you look at Salomon, North Face,
and athletes like Rebecca Rusch, and Hilaree Nelson,
Conrad Anker, Alex Honnold,
Ricky Gates, Kilian Jornet,
these brands are on board with these athletes
for their life, it's like, "Go be awesome.
Just go out and do cool stuff,
and we're here to support you."
And people love those brands as a result,
it just seems better.
Obviously, look Kilian and Ricky,
they do interesting different types of things in running,
it's not track and field where there's a stopwatch,
and it's really about metrics.
But I think there's something to be learned
from those brands
who have been doing it for a very long time.
And now other sports are trying to catch up to that.
I mean, surfing, it's the same thing
with surfers and all the kind of surf brands.
Absolutely.
And I think one thing a lot of these sports have in common
is that they're all lifestyle sports
in that a lot of the kind of like
traditional professional sports
that we think of in the United States,
at least like football, basketball,
yes, you can continue doing them post collegiately,
but there's this almost understanding that like,
"You're not going to be in the NFL,"
or there's kind of this separation where like,
"I probably can't play again,
unless we're doing a pickup game,
or I really assembled 20 people.
It's probably harder to join a league. "
It's a lot of,
it almost takes a lot of scrappiness and ingenuity
to make sure you can keep playing.
But sports like surfing, rock climbing, running,
there's no barrier.
There's no, "Hey, I need to find six guys to play with.
And even then
we need to find another six guys to play against."
You can just lease a $80 pairs of shoes and go for a run.
And I think kind of having that opportunity
to really touch so many more people makes the idea of this,
the way we're kind of talking about these,
umbrella them into these little big sports,
really should lean more towards the
how are you talking to that every day athlete?
Because there's so many more of them out there.
And it's not to say that you have to talk to them,
and therefore dumbed down how you're talking about running,
or almost make it something where it's like
you're not almost taking the running side of it seriously,
but instead you can lift all those people up with you
and say like,
"Hey, I think you deserve to know how to recover
like I recover.
I think you deserve to know how to train like I train,
and we can help you come up with ways to
build that into your life, and your schedule,
and just almost create this incredibly supportive community
that I think in a way
a lot of the traditional professional sports
kind of don't have the opportunity to tap into.
Well, it's purely based on inspiration.
You have the LeBrons and people like that that are just gods
that we look up to.
And if they say buy this product,
we're expected to buy it, right?
The difference that you're speaking to is being,
yes, you're inspirational, but you didn't go to the Olympics
and win five gold medals, right?
You're a much more accessible human being.
And so, you're more aspirational.
People aren't gonna be able to run as fast as Mary Cain,
but, "I like Mary Cain, and she's cool,
and she's gonna come out and run with us,
and she's going to help us along the way,"
there's a relationship aspect of it.
It's not just somebody on the billboard that
if you saw them in person, you would freak out.
Exactly, and I think the truth is
even the athletes who win five Olympic gold medals,
can still almost do that in running
compared to other sports.
And it's because at the end of the day
running is something that you don't need
that much extra stuff to do, right?
If you have a road, if you have a trail,
if you have a track and,
some people don't even wear a pair of shoes,
you can go out and run.
And the sort of training I'm doing versus somebody else,
yeah, you might not run as much,
maybe the times are gonna be different,
but you could still go out there and do an interval workout.
You could still go out there and run a long run,
and just build it to what works for you.
But whether you're the Olympic champion 20 times,
or this is your first time running,
you really have something in common,
and there's this ability to, I believe connect,
in a way that's just really not,
or really overlooked right now in an unfortunate way.
Yeah, well, you're also running around New York City
just everybody else, right?
Running is one of the few sports where
track and field is different, but road running,
trail running, the elites are running the same course
at essentially the same time as everybody else.
So it gives it a different vibe entirely.
And I think Tracksmith is this great
kind of platform for you to do that,
but I wanna talk about Atalanta.
How do you say it?
Atalanta.
I wanna know where this word came from,
but because you're really inverting the whole business model
with what you're doing with this new team.
Yeah, so I think just to start off,
I'll maybe explain the name which is,
in sixth grade, being the nerd that I am, I took Latin.
And at the very beginning of the year
we had to pick a mythological name,
and that would be the name we'd be called
throughout the year.
And at the time I was not a runner.
I had run a 5:47 mile as a sixth grader just as
an afterschool gym thing.
Right.
I'm not a runner. I just ran 5:47 in sixth grade.
What?
Yes.
So I acknowledge that into much just to say-
I take back all the stuff about you being relatable,
but go ahead.
When I went to my dad who had taken
kind of years of Latin himself and I was like,
"Oh, what should be the name I take?"
He immediately was like,
"That 5:47 let's do Atalanta."
And the reason is it's this really beautiful Greek myth
about a woman who is a human being, they're not a goddess,
but they're the fastest being in the world.
And they're faster than all men,
they're faster than all the gods and the goddesses.
And so much of their myth is this more feminist based myth.
I mean, as much as they go.
Like a "La Strada" kind of thing.
Yes, where it's like she is a warrior, an athlete-
Right, like from the "Wonder Woman" Island.
Exactly.
What about Achilles?
They just kicked him to the curb?
She's faster.
And so, I always love that,
for seven years when I took Latin, that was my Latin name.
And it was just one of those stories that always
was kind of in the back of my head.
And then recently when I was going on this endeavor
to start a program
I mentioned like, "Oh, we're coming up with names,"
and I threw that out there
to one of my coworkers in New York Road Runners,
and it turns out
the first ever women's high-performance team in the US
was based in New York City in the 1970s
and that was their name.
Wow. That's cool.
And I immediately was like,
"There's never really been a professional team in New York,
but that is the closest thing that's come to it."
And I'm like, "Let's bring it back."
Wow, I just got goosebumps. That's very cool.
Thank you.
And so this is set up,
this is the other interesting thing here.
You've set this up as a nonprofit.
So it's a nonprofit, but then,
and it's got kind of two prongs as I understand it.
There's going to be this elite running team
of six to eight athletes,
and then there's a whole community arm
that entails the outreach,
and getting kids on the track and all of that.
But, the professional athletes
that are gonna comprise this team
are gonna be paid employees of the nonprofit.
That's never been done before, that's super interesting.
Yeah, so one thing that I'll immediately call out is that
certain teams across the country,
in Olympic movement sports are registered as non-profits.
And the reason is, is the Amateur Athlete Act of some year
made it so that that was an opportunity.
But we're not a non-profit in name only, we're a nonprofit
and that we're actually gonna be doing
service work in the community.
And in many ways I had just always seen this problem
of the elite and of sport in wanting to solve it.
And my relationship with Tracksmith
was one in which I realized
giving athletes a full time employment opportunity
where they're building career skills,
taking on an actual job
while still being fully supported to train,
is an incredible model,
and one in which I was always trying to figure out like,
"How can I grow this?
How can I give more people this opportunity?"
But I think the thing that kept kind of
sticking in the back of my head is
it will be great to help the professional side of sport,
but how can I make this bigger?
How can I help people who maybe
never aspire to go on the professional end?
And to me, that was giving back to
younger athletes in the local community
who just maybe have been left behind in terms of programming
to get them into sport, and stay at sport,
and not only do it for this performance end,
but learn all of the skills around healthy sport,
and keeping a positive mindset.
And a lot of the things that
maybe as a young girl had I learned,
would have helped me maintain a more positive relationship
with sport forever when instead I kind of ended up falling
through this period of time where I almost left it.
Yeah.
Putting that Fordham business degree to work.
It's coming in handy right now, right?
My pre-med has been very much left behind.
And I like how,
you sent me the deck for this venture
and as I'm scrolling through it,
I liked how robust the part was
about the community outreach,
and working with kids, and the mentor, it wasn't.
There's almost a greenwashing thing with this stuff
where it's like, "Oh yeah, we're doing that.
But it's not really about that
because it's gonna be about these eight team members
and how we're gonna crush it,"
but the feeling that I got was that
that's actually the very real part of it,
and even the mindfulness that went into,
the intention that went into like,
"We're not gonna go to the parks
where this stuff already exists.
We're gonna identify the parks where this doesn't exist,
and we're going to establish that,
and it's gonna be an afterschool thing,
and a Saturday morning thing.
And there's gonna be always two mentors,
and two athletes from the team."
You've thought this through.
Yeah, this has been a few months coming at this point.
We technically incorporated in December of 2020.
And I probably started working on it sometime in November.
And the reason it's taken this amount of time
to fully launch and get off the ground
is because I wanna do it right,
and I wanna do it in a way where
it's not like I'm leaning too heavily on one side
versus the other,
but instead I want this to be a nonprofit
that outlast my running career.
I want there to be a certain point where
we've gone through three, four iterations of athletes
who have all been able to move on to their next step
post-career, and I am a part of that journey.
And the only way you can have that
is if you set a really strong foundation.
And in particular on the service side where I
totally honestly have less expertise,
and therefore had to lean on more people,
and work with others,
and set up an advisory board in which
I was getting that level of support
to really make that service dream a reality,
has been really, really incredible,
and something that I just,
I can't wait for the first program.
Yeah, do you know who the elite athletes are gonna be?
Is the team already-
I can't name people yet because we're-
The answer is yes, but you're not gonna tell me.
Exactly.
We're primarily recruiting NCAA athletes.
And so, that's as much as I'll say,
but I think the big thing is
who we're recruiting in this maybe more abstract way,
are women who are excited by this,
who are buying into the system,
who say yes the ability to one,
just give back and develop mentorship skills,
go through the appropriate training
to be able to perform this service work
is something that I think a lot of women who,
I'm technically the end of the line for millennials
based on textbooks.
So most of these girls are-
You're on a Gen Z borderline.
Exactly.
So most of these girls are the generation below me.
And I think this idea of giving back
is something that really, really resonates with them.
And the ability to actually develop career skills,
and take on a true job while at the same time
having their professional running career fully supported
is something that I think people are excited about because
when you think of great athletes,
you think of the Meghan Rapinoes of the world.
And the thing is,
Megan is an incredibly talented soccer player,
we love watching her on the field,
but Megan means more to the world
than her soccer performance.
And I think as younger athletes kind of look up at that
generation of greatness,
they realize that the people who they really are inspired by
are those who are advocates in some way,
or giving back in some way.
Greatness happens off the field as much as it on.
And I think that kind of recognition
is something that makes them think,
"Hey, this can be my star."
Yeah.
I think that's right, and I think that's powerful.
Young people, whether it's athletes
or just activists in general,
people who have a cause that they care about,
and they make their lives meaningful in that regard,
that's become an aspirational thing for young people,
which makes me optimistic about the future.
You know what I mean?
It's not enough to just go kill it and win a race.
Who are you and what are you about?
And how are you using that responsibility
in whatever platform you've established as a result of that
to actually create the world, create a better world?
Exactly, and I mean,
I would say the same thing where it gives me a lot of hope
'cause of course whenever you're starting something new,
and never done before, and completely unique,
there's that fear of,
for all of the people who I've had buy in
because they've joined my board, or donated,
or coming on as sponsors,
will I then turn towards the athletes
and be kind of told no again and again and again.
And I think to just feel the excitement in those were
going to be bringing on,
and knowing that there's this understanding
of being a part of something bigger,
and also being a part of change.
And this is something where I don't want us to be
the first and the only,
I want this to become a model that's taken seriously.
Heck if other organizations wanna step up
and do the same thing, to me that's incredible,
and that shows that I'm doing something
that can really push the sport forward.
But if it just ends up having to be me
starting this in different cities across the world,
that's another thing too that I'll try.
Yeah. No, it's super cool.
I mean, I think in the wake of you
coming out and sharing your story,
if you had just
found a way to fall back in love with running,
and maybe performed well,
most people would be like, "That's cool."
But you've really taken this on,
shouldered this responsibility to be an example
of the change that you're speaking about.
You're not just talking about it,
you actually are doing something.
Yeah, and I think that's always been something
that's been really important to me in this process.
And I feel for a while I've been
just dying to tell people about this
'cause I'm really doing read something.
But I think it's just kind of that cliche of,
I didn't wanna just talk the talk,
I wanted to walk the walk,
and I try to do that in my day to day anyway
the way I talk to myself and treat myself,
I try to exude this idea of healthy sport as best as I can,
and I try to give back to our local running community,
but I just always felt like
there was something bigger that I could be doing.
And I think part of it is that
New York City has never had a professional team,
and to be actually bringing one to this community
that in so many ways kept me in the sport,
feels like the ultimate thank you.
Because it's a way for us to not just uplift
the girls that we're servicing in the local community,
but also the broader running community of New York,
and hopefully help create something
that gets even more excitement,
and drives even more people to Central Park to run with.
And just, yeah, I think it's gonna be something where
there's a lot to learn and a lot to do,
but I'm excited for that.
How are you bankrolling this whole thing is?
Is Tracksmith a partner?
Or where does the funding come from?
Yep, they'll be an apparel sponsor of the program,
but how we're also differentiating ourselves
is it's not just a one apparel sponsor footing the bill,
instead, we're kind of taking this
multi revenue approach to the program.
So, where you have sponsorships such as Tracksmith,
and then donations are another opportunity
for us to be able to grow
because we are again, a service-based nonprofit,
and then lastly,
we are going to unveil a membership side to this
where if you wanna get training programs,
if you want to get behind the scenes
kind of access to the athletes,
we're trying to be much more open as an organization,
and not just use the mentorship skills that we develop
to give back to the younger athletes,
but to also have actual programming that
if you're a member of the organization,
we're hosting weekly, biweekly events,
and there's conversations with experts,
and there's almost a lot of the programming
that we will be doing in the parks,
also being given to our members.
That's great.
So when's this whole thing kickoff?
June.
It's happening.
So very soon.
Yeah, that's cool.
We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast,
and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing Change."
Featuring excerpts from,
poignant essays by, and glorious photography
of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show,
and copious wisdom shared there in,
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form that
provides a great taste of what we do here at the RRP,
and serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available,
and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
We got to get back to the,
we kind of diverted from the timeline.
It's all good.
No, it's good, I wanted to hear all about that.
This is the best part.
Back to the Nike Oregon Project and when you were running.
So, you're starting to have disordered eating issues.
You end up not being able to have your period
for three years or something that.
Yeah, three and a half.
And then you end up having
five stress fractures.
And that's the result of when you're not menstruating,
you're starting to have all kinds of
bone density issues, right?
Yeah, I had bone loss,
and my numbers had started to get
to a concerningly low level.
And it took a lot of intervention
to restrengthen them as much as I could
because between the years of 18 to 22
are your peak bone growth,
and I didn't have my period between the ages of
18 and 21 and a half.
Yeah, it's so pretty bad.
Yeah.
It reminds me,
I spoke about this with Lauren Fleshman,
who I know you know,
and it really speaks to,
again, this systemic issue of
this kind of male dominated paradigm,
where the men who are the support system and the coaches
are training women fundamentally like men,
and built into that is this assumption that
that women's bodies adapt and change
in the same way that dudes do, and it's just not the case.
The way that the female body sort of matures over time
is extremely different.
You were talking about, yeah, when you're a girl,
and you're starting to put on a little bit of weight,
that's normal.
But that hammer to just always keep your weight down,
always keep your weight down,
leading people into this situation of disordered eating.
I mean, it's really a big problem.
Yeah, and I think
a big thing I always like to start off saying is that
whenever I say women's training
needs to be different than men,
we can train as hard as guys,
if anything, I think the women can train harder.
Some of the workouts I've seen people do,
we can grind.
But there are certain things that are different
and need to be accounted for.
Even just the fact that
over the course of a four week period of time
there are so many studies about,
if you're in your PMS week,
bluntly you're probably not
gonna be performing quite as well
and that doesn't mean you shouldn't push through,
and sometimes kind of continued to grind,
but there should be this acknowledgement that,
okay, maybe the sort of times we're targeting this week
can be a little adjusted.
Or if you're in a program that build for three weeks
and drops for a week,
maybe if we try to align that with that week,
that'd be more beneficial.
So super kind of sciencey oriented opportunities
are something that very, very few people talk about.
But the other thing is that for women,
how we're built physically and how we develop,
guys it's just an upward trajectory perpetually-
Yeah, it's pretty straight forward.
Girls, there's always that kind of college year slump,
and that's okay, that's just a thing,
and maybe one girl doesn't experience that,
maybe one girl hits it really, really hard,
but if you're lifted through that
and you're supported through that,
then you're gonna get to 22,
and then you're gonna have that kind of like resurgence of,
kind of like knowing your body,
and your body kind of being in this space where it's done-
Yeah, well, there's a later peak to it, right?
And understanding that there's gonna be peaks and valleys
through those interim years,
and not making a big to-do about that,
or having it be a referendum
on how the rest of your career is gonna play out
I think is really important.
And I think that change only happens
when you are staffing these teams with women coaches
and women psycho,
it's like you gotta have people who understand this,
who can help these young women through this process,
and not hold them to expectations
that are ultimately not in their long-term best interests
as an athlete.
Exactly 'cause I think one thing too is that,
all of the issues that I've spoken about,
REDS, Relative Energy Deficiency in Sport,
which is essentially when you're under fueling,
and or over-training,
and, or therefore developing different physical reactions
such as bone loss, men can experience that as well.
But the bar at which you start to break down
is easier for women to hit,
and it's because physically
we're supposed to carry a little bit more fat,
where we have this almost,
our fail safe of reproductive health
is gonna drop before a man's does.
And as a result, we almost,
it's not that we can't push ourselves as hard,
but going over the red line too often is more risky.
There's more opportunities for things to start to break down
just 'cause biologically we're different.
And I think that's why having people who understand,
and can relate, and sympathize,
and have their own experiences such as other female coaches
or support staff is always going to be helpful.
But it's also incredibly important so that
the men who are also in those positions,
and also want to be coaching or support staff,
do the work,
and put in the time, and educate themselves and,
I think that's
can be said about so many different things.
Just as we need more women in sport,
we need more diverse individuals getting these positions.
And I always say that any culture that supports inclusivity,
and supports diversity,
and supports this ability to have
different opinions in a room,
and different experiences in a room and backgrounds,
is always going to be a better culture
than one in which it's just one type of person.
So for as much as we need more women,
we also need more people of all sorts of backgrounds
being able to be in those positions because
that just the ability to find ways to relate
with one another, and it's just super powerful.
Yeah, there's always gonna be the cult of personality
with certain coaches though.
It kind of feels like that's the way it is.
Maybe that can change, I don't know.
I think when we're talking about this,
we're talking about biology and physiology,
but there's also the psychology of all of it, right?
Absolutely.
On the one hand, we should point out that
weight is a factor in performance
in running and in lots of sports.
So it's not about, "Hey, we can't talk about that,"
or, "That's a verboten subject,"
but maybe don't make your athletes weigh themselves
in front of the other athletes.
There's a way of doing this, right?
So, how do you have a productive,
if you're a coach or you're an athlete,
how do you talk about this in a meaningful, productive way?
Well, I think the first thing is that
you have to do get yourself educated.
And whether it's things like SafeSport training,
or working with a nutritionist yourself or having,
and also, I'm gonna actually backtrack,
registered dietician,
especially if you're with younger athletes,
I really recommend working with somebody who's done
the full training
that's required to have a dietician's degree.
I think nutritionism is like kind of this buzz word,
but the truth is the more you're working with true experts
and people who have devoted their life
to understanding this,
the better equipped your going to be
because most coaches aren't registered dieticians,
and most coaches maybe have not had
that level of education on this topic.
So the more you're leaning on people who have
is super important.
And I think another thing is, as a coach,
you also have to work with somebody
like a therapist or a psychologist
to also make sure you're not bringing any of your
kind of own perspectives onto the track.
And I think that's really important because
a lot of these issues we're talking about
are being talked about really loudly right now.
But if you were maybe an athlete in the 90s,
and you yourself kind of went through these experiences
even if you know they were wrong,
I think so often people kind of bring their own history,
and their own maybe discomfort with food into things.
So I think that kind of first step is take care of yourself,
get the education that you can,
work with the professionals that you can,
and see if you can also kind of find out
where your own biases lie, that's number one.
And then number two is really encourage your athletes
to similarly work with those people.
And once you've maybe assembled that team,
or have a list of resources,
try to find ways to build that into your programming,
and really make sure that the language around food,
and the language around weight,
and body inclusivity is always as positive as you can.
And if you're not the professional,
do not pretend to be that.
So if you are concerned about an athletes weight
being too heavy, for example,
that's not really your place to
give them a weight that they need to hit
because there is no ideal weight, you don't know,
the registered dietician would look at you like,
"That's not a thing.
You can't give somebody an arbitrary number."
And so I think the more you kind of
try to stay in your lane,
try to direct people to the resources
that truly are going to help them
while at the same time educating yourself
as much as possible is important.
Right, and if you're a coach
maybe don't bully or athletes,
and talk shit about the other athletes
in front of the other athletes,
and create some crazy culture of fear
so that Mary Cain has to go steal cliff bars and
nibble on them in the dark.
Thank you Nathan.
You could be caught, right?
So, look, this whole thing plays,
I mean, basically in pretty short shrift
after you end up in Oregon, it's not working out, right?
How long were you there before you're like,
"I'm outta here and I'm done with all this."
So I think the big thing to say is that
I left Portland by the end of my freshman year.
So I was out there for about a year.
But, and this is where I always kick myself looking back,
that wasn't some big,
"Oh, this was bad, I'm leaving," moment.
This was more me apologizing to everybody because-
You couldn't live up to Alberto's standards.
Yes.
You couldn't cut it.
Exactly.
So I moved home to New York and I told everybody like,
"I have disordered eating.
I have been trying to make myself throw up,
and I can't do this, this is super unhealthy.
I'm cutting myself,
my mental health is fully deteriorating.
I'm really sorry,
but I just need to figure this out and then I'll come back."
So that was the plan.
Just to back up for a second.
When you, cause you told,
did you tell Alberto,
or one of the coaches that you were cutting yourself, right?
And what was the response?
It was after this race that had been delayed.
And so, it was late at night,
and I was truthfully having a full breakdown.
And I was really scared that I was gonna hurt myself.
And so, I went to Alberto and the sports psychs room,
and I told them like,
"I just tried to make myself throw up
multiple times the bathroom.
I've been cutting myself,"
at this point the sports had already caught me doing it
a couple of times, so he knew that I was.
And I was like, "I don't know what to do.
I really need help."
And this is the other thing that always makes me cry.
I was told that they wanted to go to sleep
because it was late.
And that crushed me in a way that
I don't know what I thought they were gonna do,
but I think I just thought they would do something.
And so, the next day I called my mom,
who I at that point, I hadn't been talking to
honestly and openly.
And I told her I have
a really bad relationship with food now.
And I didn't tell her that I was cutting myself at the time,
I was too embarrassed.
And so, my mom and dad at that point had been
not spoken to by the coaches for awhile.
There'd been too many moments of red flags,
and me saying something and then getting in trouble,
and then part of being scattered across the country.
And so, they booked a flight home.
The next day I got on a plane to New York,
and the plan was I'm going to get myself back together
so that I'm tough enough to rejoin the team fully.
So I spent a year in New York during which-
So that was always the plan to go back.
And let's just pause for a moment.
I mean, I'm so sorry that that happened to you and,
it's infuriating that you would go to,
was it the psychologist person?
And literally say like,
"This is what I'm doing and I need help."
And that person says, "I'm tired, I need to go to bed."
I mean, it's just unbelievable.
Yeah, and I mean,
he had caught me doing it a couple of times,
and both times it was just kind of knock it off,
and waved off and-
That's helpful.
He'd seen me self-harm myself in other ways as well.
There was a track workout in which,
and a lot of people witnessed this, unfortunately,
but I started hitting myself,
and I, so sad, but I was racing 400.
And if you've ever been to Nike's track
there's trees in the middle.
So I ran a 200, and I ran off the track,
and I ran towards where the bridle is.
And I don't know what was in my head,
I think I just wanted to get off campus,
and run into traffic honestly.
And the sports tech ran after me, I was hitting myself,
and they dragged me back onto the track,
and I had to finish the workout.
And in those moments,
I think what people don't always recognize is that
to me even saying this now,
I'm so embarrassed that I did that.
To me, even though I know everything that had happened,
that feels very unprofessional.
So when I'm being told at 18
that you're being super unprofessional, knock it off,
get on the track, finish it.
You're already in a really bad place.
So you're not thinking, "Hey, why aren't you helping me?
This is clearly a sign of distress."
Instead I'm thinking, "Yeah, I agree with you.
This is super unprofessional. I'm really sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm disrupting the workout.
Is everybody else okay?
Okay, I'm gonna cry myself around the track now
for the next four laps."
And I say that not to really do anything more than,
for anybody right now who's had that sort of experience
where they relate to the fact that
something wasn't done for them,
but rather than kind of recognize it as wrong
in that moment and it maybe even right now,
they were still saying, sorry, don't say, sorry.
In those moments,
the right thing to do would have been get me help.
In those moments the right thing
that anybody should have done
was shut that down and intervene.
Right.
And if anybody should have had the wherewithal to do that,
it's the Nike Oregon Project,
the most well-funded elite track and field situation
perhaps in the world.
It would be one thing if it was some high school track coach
that didn't know any better, and he's like,
"All right, well,"
maybe that guy just is not trained to
know what to do in that situation,
but it's really inexcusable
that that went down the way that it did.
Yeah, and I mean, to this day,
I have no idea if any of those individuals
are SafeSport certified.
And if they are, they're,
I mean, I am,
and there are multiple modules where you can't watch that
and not be like,
"Well, we've broken 40 of these rules
for so many different times?"
Yeah, well, I think there's a lot of education
that needs to be done around that.
And also the scope of what SafeSport is about
because I think there's this sense
that it's about sexual abuse or doping only,
and that's kind of the limits.
I think people need to better understand that
it does expand to
all of these kinds of mental health situations.
Yeah, and it's not at all about doping,
it's all about really like a coach's guidebook to abuse,
and what not to do.
And I think they really
incredible thing about their programming
is the fact that it's real,
I mean, it's really well done,
and it's done by professionals,
and I recommend every single individual
that works with any sort of athlete,
whether you're a parent, whether you're an athlete yourself,
a coach, an AD,
get yourself SafeSport certified,
even if it's not required of you.
And the reason is there are so many different things
that I even look back on my experience and I'm like,
"God, that was part of the toxicity."
If you're working with a 16 or 17 year old,
they probably shouldn't stay in your house
when they're traveling.
You probably shouldn't be texting each other every day.
And all of those sort of barriers
that create this sense of almost connection,
or this family bond, if you will,
are really not positive things because this is a child,
and you shouldn't be overstepping like that.
And so when things start to go wrong,
that kid's first thought is gonna be like,
"This person is like my uncle. I can't let them down."
Yeah, well, it's more than that.
This is the person who's going to help me realize my dream.
And this is the person who believes in me,
and who is telling me that I'm capable of these things.
It's unbelievably intoxicating.
Yes.
But what the point that I'm trying to make is
I understand well how potent and powerful that dynamic is.
And when you're a young person and you're impressionable,
you don't want your parents,
your parents, what they have to say is irrelevant.
You're protecting this very,
you feel very special.
You are the person who is touched,
and you are going places,
and everybody else, "Get out of the way,
and I'm gonna listen to what this coach says."
And you have no ability to gauge the unhealthy nature of it
because you don't know any different.
No, and you're looking at your teammates,
and whenever you ask them for help, they're saying like,
"Buy in, stop complaining, do what you're told.
He's the best coach.
He's gonna get you to the top."
I think an elephant in the room
that maybe it needs to be addressed with all of this is that
my old coach, Alberto, isn't just banned by SafeSport,
he's also banned by USADA.
And so, in retrospect
there's always that part of me that's like,
"I kept saying no to thyroid medication.
I kept saying no to using an inhaler.
I didn't use birth control for weight loss reasons
because I knew at that point
there were deeper problems going on and that was not-"
The birth control was his means of addressing
the period thing, right?
No.
No? I misread that then.
So he has since said that,
but the reason I was put or I didn't actually take it,
so I wasn't, I was given physician samples birth control
from his own doctor who was friends with him,
is because he felt that I was bloating a lot.
And he felt some of my weight might be because
this is just gonna all sound crazy
because I was really still cycling and maybe still PMSing,
but just not bleeding.
Sorry for that,
I should've given a content warning for that.
And as a result, he thought some of my weight
was because I was super bloated,
and we needed to de bloat me.
And so, that's why diuretics had been thrown out,
diuretics are not allowed, I said, no.
And then birth control became this thing that he decided
would really help me lose the weight,
which doesn't make any sense, it isn't a thing.
But I was brought into the doctor.
She gave me birth control
because he wanted me to lose weight.
And the thing is,
if I went in there and I said,
"Hi, I'm an 18 year old girl,
I want birth control for birth control purposes,"
they can give you,
they can kind of just give them to you, right?
But if I go in-
Like samples.
Yes.
But if I go into the doctor's office with my coach,
who I'm not related to,
and they sit through the whole appointment
and talk about how I need to lose weight,
"We think birth control is gonna help,"
and they give them to you-
Yeah, that's crazy.
That's insane.
That's crazy.
What other kind of doping stuff did you see,
or that was omposed upon you?
I think the thing is, and I always come back to this is,
I was just the person who always said no.
And it wasn't from anything other than the fact that,
again, I think I took so much of this like,
"Oh no, they probably don't even know
diuretics aren't allowed.
Let me explain to them that I'm not gonna take them because
make sure you never encourage somebody else to do it
kind of way."
The 17, 18 year old is gonna explain it to the-
Exactly.
And I think a big thing was, really early on,
I was always,
everything had to be triple checked with the Global DRO,
which is how you know something's banned.
So I would eat Tums and be panicky
trying to figure out if Tums were bad, right?
So, that was a big thing when I was in high school.
And then as soon as I went out there,
it kind of became more like, "No, you're good."
And it was kinda more like,
"Hey, I know your dad had said thyroid might be bad before,
but your numbers are kind of on the lower end.
They're not low, but maybe we should do this."
And I'd be like,
"No, my dad has said you're not supposed to take that
if you don't need it."
Or it would be like,
"Hey, you're always breathing really heavy while running.
Maybe you have asthma, maybe you need an inhaler."
Right, always trying to find
the medical exemption so that you could get the-.
Yes, and I was given an inhaler at some point.
I never took it 'cause I remember again, being so like,
"Guys, I think you're making a mistake," and again-
And are you getting the periodic knock on the door
and doing the, getting drug tested?
Yeah, I was drug tested a ton.
And I always joke,
I was in that big Fancy Bear's leak,
my information was threatened to be leaked,
but on it it said two Flintstone Vitamins,
and two iron tablets, and vitamin D,
and so, they never released it.
And I felt so both vindicated,
but also kind of put out that I'm on food still vitamins,
like, "Watch them cower," as I walk out to the track.
But the thing is I was always saying no,
and it was always coming back to weight of like,
"Well, you need this
because thyroid can make you skinnier too,
and birth control for weight loss."
And I think that's just important to say
because sometimes it also just makes me be
when the other athletes were like, "Just buy in already,"
was that something else?
And the answer is, I don't know.
And sometimes I wish I could go back
and have been more conscious in those moments
of what was really going on but-
Was there pressure from the other athletes
to get on board with some kind of protocol?
Well, we did have a team bonding trip and during it,
one of the athletes did tell me that
I needed to step up and stop being such a baby.
And kind of either you got to buy in
or you're not on the team sort of talk.
And it was funny 'cause it was this team bonding trip.
And I was the first person to talk,
and I was like, "This was so much fun,
we made memories and friendship, and I'm 12."
And then the next person to go was like,
"You have to step it up.
You either have to be professional,
or off this team" kind of talk,
and I was like, "Well, the friendships are over."
So I think it's just,
I'm only saying this because I think in so many ways,
the reason that this system of current sponsorship
is troubling is because all lines become blurred.
Because if everything is about performance, right?
Well, things like weight is gonna be overstepped.
But how much of the weight overstepping was because
there was maybe a want for cheating the habit?
I don't know.
And so, when everything is about performance,
then kind of however you get there,
people act like it's okay.
And if it means burning some people out,
if it means stepping all over people,
if it means treating people poorly,
it's not personal, it's business
was always the catch phrase that I used to hear.
And I'm like businesses that operate like this aren't good.
And usually ultimately that comes to light,
and there has to be a reckoning.
And I think society should never condone
that sort of behavior for the sake of performance
because there are plenty of people who are performing
incredibly and who don't do that.
Well, this did all come out.
I mean, all of this was going on for you in 2015, right?
Yeah, so 2015, 2016, I was still on the team.
What ultimately happened was that again,
I had kind of wanted just,
I stayed on the team,
and I wanted to ultimately
be back on the team in this full way.
But as I had mentioned earlier,
I had never told my parents about the cutting.
They only knew that I was struggling with food.
And after the Olympic trials,
my current coach, John Henwood, caught me cutting myself.
He immediately called my parents, and was like,
"I'm really sorry.
She asked me not to call you, but I'm really scared for her.
And I don't know what to do.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do in this situation,
but I'm here with her.
I need help."
He did what you're supposed to do.
He did what a grownup would do.
And I was so mad at him.
And he admitted
that he didn't know.
And he admitted that he didn't know how to handle it.
And I was so mad at him for years afterwards.
And I have always loved John.
It wasn't like that,
but to me it was like this horrible moment because one,
I was super embarrassed,
and now my parents know, and that's embarrassing.
And two, my parents were like, "You have to leave this team.
This is destroying you.
This is tearing you apart. You have to leave."
And I think there was a period of time
where my parents could not understand
why I so couldn't see that the system was a problem.
And I think part of it was
they didn't know a lot of these stories,
these stories that I'm telling now.
I sat my parents down
before "The New York Times" piece came out,
and I just told them everything.
And so, there's so many more moments that
I've never talked about, and aren't even public
that they almost saw what was happening to me,
but they didn't even know how it was happening.
But, they told me like, "This is a bad set up for you.
You have to have health being your number one."
And so, I left the team and then the sad irony is that
that's when my body was finally like,
"You've been doing damage for so many years."
My bone density was lowered substantially,
and then I started to break.
And it was this kind of tragic,
yes, I had the left,
but I think because I didn't actually let go,
and I didn't actually understand
what was wrong with the situation
that it just I was in this cycle.
And the truth is what snapped me out of it was
when the USADA report came out in which Alberto was banned,
my first, my immediate reaction was like,
"No way, he didn't do anything,"
that was literally my first reaction to it.
And I the next day read the whole entire report,
it's 270 pages.
I read it word for word.
And holy crap,
it was the first time I saw on paper that they lied.
And there's so many moments in it where
it'll say something like,
"Athletes on the team were told that
USADA I had given them permission to do blank," right?
And I had been told that, I thought that was true,
of course, yes.
This giant company that's telling me that,
"We got full approvals, don't worry about it,
all these allegations are lies."
You're kind of like,
"I don't know, they're worth billions of dollars,
I think they're telling the truth."
What's your sense of how high up that went at Nike?
Very.
The CEO stepped down. That high?
I mean, he was in on the emails.
And again, some of this stuff happened
before I was on the team, actually almost all of it did.
Yeah, and all these people have come out
going back to 2008, right?
Telling stories about this.
Yeah.
And so, I was always,
there was no,
I almost was never there firsthand.
I was only ever hearing things second hand
because I joined the team in 20,
well, I started working with Alberto in 2012.
Seriously actually joined the team in 2013,
and it was around then
that allegation started to pop up, right?
So I'm already in the bubble, I'm already in the system.
And when you're being told like, "No, that was misconstrued.
All 10 of us are saying, this was actually what happened,
you weren't there but here's some story,"
you're kind of like, "I trust these people.
They're my friends.
They wouldn't do me wrong."
And so, as I was reading the USADA report,
there were all of these moments of me being like,
"Oh my God, USADA is telling me that I was lied to.
And I'm one of the athletes
that they're sub-tweeting this thing
of saying that they thought this was the thing,"
and I was just frozen.
And even now trying to describe the feeling
it's like I had just so many emotions run through me
because that was when the flood opened for me internally,
and I suddenly was like,
"Whoa, if everything in this was a lie,
then what else was happening
that I've never let myself come to terms with?"
And the thing is had you talked to me
the day before the USADA report came out,
and you looked me in the eye and you said,
"I know everything you went through,
you were emotionally abused,"
put a laugh at your face,
I would've walked away I mean like,
What is that guy talking about?"
But as soon as I knew,
I could look back on my experience and I could see the lies,
and I could see the abuse for what it was,
that was the most, both empowering and terrifying moment.
Right, it shatters the illusion.
Complete shattering.
And, again, I think really the scary thing about abuse
is that the reason it takes years for people to come out
is because so often they don't even know that's what it was.
And for me, it was like as soon as I knew
that was what had happened,
my first thought was,
"Holy crap. There's other people who don't know."
And that's scary.
It also explains why you wanted back on the team, right?
Which is part and parcel of Nike's big defense
in all of this like,
"What do you mean she's saying all this stuff?
She was trying to get back on the team.
I'm like, "Yeah, of course."
We didn't know about any,
so, right.
So, well, Salazor gets banned in September of 2019, right?
So does that report come out in advance of that,
or did those things, they came out at the same time.
It was like they happened same moment,
and then six weeks later,
"The New York Times" piece came out.
They were the longest six weeks in my life.
So, there's a good three year period
where you go from being Mary Cain, fastest girl in America,
bright future,
Olympic glory is a foregone conclusion for this person.
There was even a "New York Times" article about you
in 2015, right?
And painted this-
Which was a whole thing.
Glorious picture,
you're whitewashing this whole experience.
But then there's this period where you disappear, right?
It's like, "What happened to Mary Cain?
She just vanished off the landscape."
You go home, you're trying to piece yourself back together
during this period of time.
It's this fallow era where
suddenly you're nowhere to be found, then...
So you're dealing with what you're dealing with
and trying to come to terms with this,
but still buying into all of it,
thinking you're gonna make your way back, right?
Until this report comes out.
And I'll say this, right?
So I was like, "I'm not tough enough. I can't handle it.
I'm maybe not built to be a pro," right?
And what ended up happening was I kind of had this injury,
and again, my parents, my coach, John, nobody,
I hadn't really shared a lot of these stories with.
There was maybe inklings of it and pieces of it,
but with everything you're just,
if I can't even look back on that,
how could I share that with somebody else?
And so, around probably the beginning of that year,
it was maybe 2018 summer,
Alberto and I had talked once,
and it was kind of meant for me to be my closure moment
of being okay, and-
And you're still getting paid by Nike though
throughout this period?
Yeah, I was still,
yeah, my contract ended December 31st, 2018.
So I was still a Nike athlete.
So it wasn't weird in a way
that there was that kind of moment.
And then kind of between then and when I was gonna be hurt
at the beginning of 2019,
he kind of kept reaching out to my coach
just to see how am I doing?
Friendly stuff, I think, okay we're fine, right?
And then I got hurt.
We asked like, "Oh, any tips?"
I ended up going out to Portland.
And for me, a lot of it was,
again, I still had this,
I felt so bad about everything that had happened.
And I talked very openly with Alberto about the fact that
I developed a really serious disordered eating.
And I use the word disorder eating
instead of eating disorder because I wasn't bulimic,
and I wasn't anorexic,
in terms of true clinically diagnosed.
Right, the clinical definitions for those.
But I under ate substantially and I was underweight a lot,
and I went through big fluctuations,
and I would try to purge and I wouldn't be successful.
So it's kind of more within that disordered eating bucket.
But I shared this and it was kind of like, "Okay."
I just had not acknowledged,
and I think that was kind of like a little bit like, wow,
I guess that's,
to me and I think at the time it was almost just like,
"Yeah, you weren't, you couldn't handle it."
And I think that was kind of like-
So in his, in other words, sorry to interrupt you.
In other words, in his mind,
you being a product and not a person,
he'd already made the decision that you were damaged goods.
Yeah, 100%.
And he's like,
"Oh, that's fine, you can come and tell me that.
But like I already knew this wasn't gonna work out
and I've moved on."
Totally, and so, you're kind of like, "Okay, cool."
But I'm still trying to try and be a pro or whatever.
But I'm at that point, pretty okay.
Maybe start that first crack
in the rose-colored glasses is hit, right?
And up until that nobody had ever hit the glasses, right?
I've just been going through life,
being that whole situation was totally normal
because everybody who was out there with me
acted like it was totally okay.
And I'm too embarrassed to tell almost people in my life
who maybe would tell me that it wasn't.
So the first cracks hit and I'm still fine.
And then just going through life.
So that once boom, the USADA report comes out.
I think it was almost this like, "Oh,"
not only do I kind of have this moment-
Like you just got,
you got red pill, right?
Like you just went into the matrix all of a sudden,
or came out of the matrix.
And who knows,
maybe had I not had that little crack in the glasses,
maybe they wouldn't have fully shattered, I have no idea.
I think they would have 'cause
if you read 270 pages of that report you're just mind blown,
recommend it, fun times.
But I think that when I came out
and I shared my story, right?
I think first off I thought nobody was gonna read it.
And I'm like my mom's gonna get me a pity watch,
and feel sad that she watched that thing,
and then there's gonna be
a small contingency of the running community.
And I honestly thought that 50% of the people,
again, maybe 10 people watch it.
Five of those people are like, "That's that."
One person is like, "Wow, that's me,"
and then the other four are like,
"That girl's fat. She was just slow."
But to me, that one person saying, "Okay, wow, that is me,"
would be worth it.
And I didn't care how many people were negative,
I didn't care at all about the response,
it was just for that one person.
And it was a Thursday morning I woke up,
and it was everywhere and I was-
17 Million people have watched on YouTube alone.
And Lord knows how many on "The New York Times" website,
it's insane.
But I wanna back into this a little bit
because there's a lot more going on here.
After the report comes out,
the rose-colored glasses are cracking a little bit.
You're coming to terms with the reality of this situation.
And on some level,
you're wrestling with the idea of going public with it.
But the initial thought was, "I'll share this on Instagram.
I'll write a little thing up,"
then bringing it back to how we started this podcast,
enter Alexi Pappas, who I didn't know
was the puppet master behind the scenes here
that put you with Lindsay Crouse,
and kind of set in motion this whole thing.
Yeah, and what it was like,
when I even first spoke to Alexi,
it was in that like very just, "I need to write.
I need to throw stuff onto paper,
almost throw this bad analogy," but it's all because-
But that's pretty fast from a crack in the glasses
to like, "I feel the need to talk about this now."
Yes, and I think it's because
they're such a frantic energy,
and this almost fear that happens in that moment.
Because I'm gonna say that
this whole situation has made me,
and this is bad,
this is something I'm working on with my therapist,
but less trusting.
And it's made me more skeptical of authority.
And it's made me question society's behavior
in a way that I just never had done before.
And I think that's really powerful,
and I think that's a great thing.
But in that moment it's really horrifying to be like,
"Oh my God, this was condoned.
This was normalized.
People acted this was okay.
And I'm realizing right now how bad this was.
And who am I kind of in this big world
to have figured it out?"
And I think knowing that I did,
it was like 24 hours ago, I didn't.
And that person almost scared me.
And I was like, "I need to help them."
And obviously I couldn't go back in time and help myself,
so how can I pass it forward to the next person?
It was my immediate reaction.
And I remember I pulled my parents aside,
maybe the next day, or really early on in this,
and I was like, "I have to tell you everything."
And we did the deep dive and we went,
this was like an hour as long conversation
of me just sharing everything.
And as soon,
there's obviously a lot of tears.
I can't even get through a podcast without crying.
And at the end, my parents' question was like,
"What are you gonna do?"
And I said, and I don't know why,
I think I'm gonna start crying,
but I was like,
"I don't think I'm ever going to be a pro runner again,
but I love the sport.
Nobody's ever gonna sign me.
Nobody's ever gonna follow me again."
I said, "But I can't live with myself if I don't share this,
and if I don't help that one person."
And I remember they were so scared for me,
and so proud of me at the same time.
And I think for them it was just like,
it was almost like this happy proud,
and this like,
"You're doing something bigger than yourself."
And again, we didn't think anybody would watch the video.
I thought if anything,
and I'm gonna be very honest when I say this,
having so many people watch that protected me
in a way that I don't know do people understand.
And had that been something where
a couple thousand people watched it,
the same negativity from one side of that conversation
would have been louder,
and it probably would have been stronger.
And you see it in how other athletes from that program
have since been treated when they left,
and when they came forward and when they were vocal,
and in many ways
that's what I thought I was going to experience.
I mean, Kara Goucher has gotten death threats.
Athletes have been called horrible things across website,
social media, they've been gaslighted.
And I was prepared for that,
that was what I was signing up for.
And the sport is one in which again,
what was done was really horrible,
and yet, a lot of the competitors of these organizations
don't necessarily turn around and say like,
"Oh, wow,
you're really trying to do something good in the world.
Let's support you."
If anything in the traditional space, it's much more like,
"No, you're not that fast anymore. Whatever."
Yeah, and everybody's running to protect their own
at the same time.
I mean, it is a David and Goliath story.
It's not just, "Hey, this is Mary Cain,
and she's gonna share her story of how hard it was."
This is you basically taking on Nike.
I mean, that's a very,
and you're a young person,
that's very scary,
and you still wanna have this career in running.
So you're gonna become,
you're risking becoming persona non grata in doing this.
And that takes an unbelievable amount of courage to do that.
And I thank you for saying that.
And I think again though the almost sad thing is that
yes, it was courageous, and yes, I was being vulnerable,
but that was pure fear that was guiding me.
And it wasn't fear of repercussions,
it wasn't fear of the big, bad guy,
it was fear that somebody was living a lie,
and hurting themselves because they didn't know it.
And it was fear for that younger version of myself.
It was that fear of that version of myself
from 72 hours before that drove me.
And I say that in so much as to say
I think these issues are terrifying.
I think the fact that we don't support and protect people,
and treat them as these incredible gifts,
and I say this in a very general way outside of sport way,
people are people they're not products.
And when organizations lose sight of that
and take advantage of people, that goes beyond sport.
Women being taken advantage of goes beyond sport.
Women being objectified, this is like,
the reason 17 million people watched it
is because it's not just a sport story,
and it's not even just a woman's story.
This is when powerful people abuse.
And what is power? It depends on the situation.
And so, there are plenty of people in the world
with power over others.
And the idea that somebody was trapped in that was,
that fear guided me.
And so, when people say I was brave or courageous,
I thank them, I appreciate that,
but this wasn't a moment for me.
This was literally me chucking the baton across the room,
and being like, "Save yourself"
because it's horrifying when you're in that.
And I couldn't get proper treatment really until I knew.
My relationship with food pre,
even during that "New York Times" piece
was weaker now than it is today.
And it's because all the work that I had done
had always been not at the root of the issue.
Well, that earnestness and that sensibility
comes across in the video for sure.
I mean, you get that.
And I think that's a big reason why
it did end up connecting with so many people.
And for people that haven't seen it,
essentially, Lindsay Crouse,
who's been on the podcast before,
accomplished runner in her own right,
is all about these issues.
She's like the perfect person for Alexi to say,
"Go see this person."
I know you contacted her and she's like,
"Come to the 'New York Times' office right now
do the meeting"
And you're like,
"I thought I was gonna do an Instagram post,"
and now you're making this movie with her.
But she really helps craft and shepherd this message
in a mindful, intentional way.
And the end product of which is,
is really palpable and powerful.
So, it's not surprising to me
that so many people have not only seen it,
but were impacted by it.
And all of this happens really quickly, right?
So the USADA Salazar thing comes out in September, right?
I will write down the timeline here
'cause it all happens really quickly.
October, Nike shuts down Oregon Project.
November, well then,
so the Nike CEO, Mark Parker steps down.
Was that before the video?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, and then November 4th,
WADA says it will investigate each athlete
that trained with Salazar.
By the way, I was never investigated, and I was one-
You weren't?
I was gonna ask you I was like,
"What's the status of that by the way?"
I was about to say, "Please investigate me.
I don't know what camera
I have to look at.
Yeah, what's going on.
Because to me- (sighs)
The story seems to end
with your video kind of-
It's so frustrating.
And your call for third-party investigation of Nike.
I couldn't find any evidence that,
there's a narrative beyond that,
it doesn't seem that that's happening.
But in any event, so November 7th then your video comes out,
and it explodes.
Yeah, and then
Alberta was SafeSports banned,
maybe a few weeks after that.
Yeah, after that, right?
Temporarily.
Is it still temporarily?
Yeah,
it's still temporarily technically.
And he's still obviously in that four year window.
Yeah.
Right.
Much sheer surprise I would suspect,
I mean, first of all, I can't imagine being you the next day
your world must've just exploded, right?
It was one of the most-
You must have been terrified,
I mean, did you even sleep the night before
that this was coming out
knowing that this was going to come out?
I woke up super early.
And I definitely had such a restless night,
and again, I thought I was gonna be super small,
50/50 negative positive,
but it still was just,
I wanted to be able to see it in the world
and then never look again, right?
That was my thought.
I thought I was gonna delete my Instagram.
Had you seen it before?
You'd seen it obviously right beforehand?
Yeah, and I was able to send it to my mom,
and you know what the really tragic thing too is?
My first thought when I watched the video
was that I was like, "I look really fat."
That was literally the first thought I had.
And I remember I called my mom and I was like,
"I think they're just gonna think I was the fat girl
who didn't do well."
And again, it's like that is how recent-
The disorder though.
And that is how recent I was to being that deep in it.
And I'll be honest, I still struggle.
But my God, a year and a half different
just because I was able to
almost stop treating just the food, but treat the PTSD.
But I was able to see it before and that morning was insane.
And the craziest thing was I was being called,
and my parents' house we're being called.
I don't even know how they were getting
my parents' phone number,
and different news outlets wanted me to
do exclusives with them.
And two competing news networks were calling me,
and one kind of kept threatening that
if I didn't do their thing,
or if I did their competitors,
then they wouldn't talk to me.
And I remember I just yelled at the woman on the phone
and I was like, "How dare you?"
I was like, "I did not do this to get on your TV show.
I did not do this
so that I could be thrust into this toxic competitive world.
I did this to help people.
If you don't wanna help people, okay."
Powerful Mary Cain.
But I'm one woman-
Laying down the law.
Literally, and I'm also like frying in the zone.
I'm a one woman PR team.
My mom barely knows how to answer my email,
"Goodbye," and I hand up the phone.
And they called me an hour later and they're like,
"Okay, we will still put you on."
And again, I didn't even care.
I thought I was gonna be
deleting and burning my social media accounts.
This was not what I thought.
There was a flurry,
I mean, everybody had to take on this.
There was so much press in the days,
two days after, or three days after this thing hit.
And Lindsay kind of warned me.
She was like, "I kind of thing this is gonna be big."
And I was just like,
"Lindsay, only runners are gonna read this."
And so, she was incredible.
And at the time I really was managing all of this by myself.
She was protecting you
'cause I reached out to her and I was like,
"Wow, this is crazy. I'd love to talk to Mary."
And she was like, "Yeah, I'm keeping a lid.
I'm trying to help her keep a lid on it right now."
She was incredible.
And when she even did was she connected me to Wes Felix,
who's Allyson Felix's brother,
and was like, "Reach out to us,"
and was like, "Alison went through this
when she did a "New York Times" piece.
Right, we have to contextualize this
because this came out,
there's a series of Nike stuff
that was all happening around this time.
Most notably, the Allyson Felix pregnancy thing.
Yes, and her brother Wes,
who is the most incredible person,
is her agent, and ultimately became mine as well.
So Lindsey reached out to him and was like,
"Mary is drowning.
She doesn't know what to do. This was very unexpected.
She's handling it as well as she can, but there's only..."
You're in this weird position, right,
where you're like, "I want to keep telling this story
'cause I can help more people."
But you're also like,
"I have no way to manage this on my own.
This is super overwhelming."
And so, he called me up and was like,
"Just anything, forward everything along to me,
I'm gonna help you sort through it.
This is just me being a friend because we've been there."
And moments like that,
and relationships being developed like that
were just, again, something I'd never experienced in track.
'Cause I'm used to being at the team bonding trip
where I'm being told man up pretty much,
and now I have somebody who I've met maybe once
and was excited 'cause I took a picture with them
being like, "Hey, I'm here to help you.
No strings attached.
You're my friend wow, let me help."
I mean, I'd never experienced that before.
You just waiting to get stabbed in the back.
Oh, 100%, I mean, I'm still,
sometimes I feel like turning around with certain people.
But Alexi is honestly the person who taught me
that you don't have to,
and that there can be comradery in sport,
and there can be
this ability to really be a teammate and what that means.
And I think,
I'm still in so many ways
now shocked with how beautiful the sport is,
and how positive it can be when you find the right people.
It had to be unbelievably gratifying and emotional
to see the outpouring of support-
I can't tell you.
From teammates and all these people
who were very frank and saying like,
"I kinda knew this was going on,
and I wish I'd said something and I didn't,"
or, "I should have," or, "I didn't know, but I should have,"
all of that, it was pretty unanimous.
Yes.
And from all over the world.
I mean, it was,
I will remember to this day when even people,
I told the story in "The New York Times"
about this one specific meet,
and how I didn't race while,
it was the meet that I ultimately afterwards
told the sports psych and Alberto that I was cutting myself,
and I didn't race well,
there was a thunderstorm, we went under a tent.
I was yelled at because I clearly gained five pounds
between this morning and the race time
because I ate bacon and eggs.
And so, I ran out into the thunderstorm.
This was honestly my most suicidal moment.
After the piece came out, athletes came forward and said,
"I was there, I saw that.
I was in the tent. I saw what happened and I'm sorry."
And that,
I would never let that girl ran out by herself,
and I never will.
But it still means a lot that people have said,
"I'm sorry, and I was there."
And for me it's about empowering that person.
And, first off,
never letting that happen in the first place.
But if that ever was to,
making sure there are 10 people running after that girl
'cause she should not have done that alone.
I'm sorry, I think I haven't talked about this a little bit.
No, I mean, it's really,
honestly, I mean, thank you for being so open about it.
And I think that recognition is beautiful,
and it's critical to your own personal healing process
with all of it.
Oh, 100%.
And I think it's also important for me
as I'm going and embarking on this new endeavor,
and creating a team, and almost learning,
it's important to learn what not to do, right?
I have a lot of experience with what not to do.
But I think the other thing is that as much as that's good,
you have to learn what to do,
and you can't almost only be coming
into this beautiful journey of creating a team
that I'm embarking on with a cynical perspective,
which I think would be really, really easy for me to do
if I'm honest.
And so, there's so much importance to me-
To fuck all those Nice guys team.
Yeah, exactly.
That's the name of the team.
Pretty much.
It's really important for me to think about
so many people who've helped me,
and so many people who supported me through that time,
like the Alexis,
or people who just, like the Wess,
who stepped up and said like, "I'm here for you."
Because those are the people who I can lean on
and learn from when creating something beautiful,
versus just kind of creating something
out of a fear of what was.
When you look on the past, it can't ever be like
I'm just trying to rewrite my own story.
It's how can I really make something good going forward?
And so that's why I do think,
although obviously I've cried multiple times,
it's healthy to talk about,
and it's important to talk about,
especially when I just held this in for so long.
And you still look back on that
moment of me running out into the thunderstorm,
which is so dramatic but literally what happened,
as being this almost example of how weak I was.
And that was the narrative.
The narrative was in my head
because this is what was told to me, "You're a head case.
This is due our fault.
You're the one failing yourself."
And for so long that's how I kind of remembered it.
And to suddenly take a step back and look at it
almost from the eyes of everybody but me,
it suddenly, wow, that's horrible that that happened,
and how can I make sure it never does again?
Yeah.
It also wasn't that long ago.
I mean, the pandemic,
anything pre-pandemic feels like 100 years ago,
but we're talking about the end of 2019
when you came out with this.
And on a personal level,
you can't be a phoenix without the fire,
you gotta burn, right?
And on a broader level in terms of running in general,
what an incredible opportunity
because you're so uniquely situated with your experience,
and the level of exposure that this story has garnered,
that you're now perfectly situated
to reimagine what the future of running can look like
for girls and women going forward.
And you've taken that, you're running with it.
You've got the Tracksmith partnership.
You've got Atalanta, I said it correctly,
that's all happening, and it's really inspiring.
And this has all happened
in a pretty compressed period of time.
I mean, I know maybe it seems like not to you,
but it sounds like it to me,
like in the grand scheme of things, and you're so young,
and you have so much running ahead of you,
and you have so much mentorship ahead of you,
it's truly inspiring.
No, and I really appreciate you saying that.
As I said this probably six weeks between the USADA report
and when "The New York Times" piece came out,
felt like the longest six weeks of my life.
And I think, I always remember that when ever I feel like,
"Oh gosh, things aren't happening quick enough,"
or, "I wanna be here by X date,"
and almost I think,
or at least my predisposition to push, push, push.
I always looked back and I'm like,
"That was only six weeks."
And so, in the scheme of things,
it has been a really, really short time,
which is also why I'm continuing to try to learn.
I think one thing
that I do sometimes feel a little uncomfortable with
is that, we're all flawed individuals, right?
And so, even me kind of taking this step as a mentor,
and as an advocate,
I have to always be very conscious
of my own place in the world,
and how I can be educating myself,
and learning new things, and kind of taking that next step.
Because for as much as I lived my experience,
there's so many other moments people can go through
that I will never experienced and I will never know.
And to take that level of learning
and kind of spread this in a way that's more inclusive,
and not just my story
can only happen if I'm constantly trying to better myself,
which is why even with this program that I'm creating
and the service side of it,
we're gonna create extensive educational standards
for all the mentors.
Because you can't just expect a young,
well, somebody of any age
to be ready to kind of teach, right?
You have to learn before you can teach.
Right.
I think you're gonna be really successful with this
because based on what you just said,
there's a real appreciation for humility,
and the level of empathy that you're able to bring to it,
it just feels, it's such a heart-centered thing for you,
and I could tell that you've thought it completely through.
So I'm excited to see what it looks like.
Yeah. Thank you.
I can't wait for this journey,
and I know everything's gonna keep going quick,
and feeling like it's taking forever,
but the more that I can stay in the present
and enjoying that moment,
I'd always be proud of where I am today,
as much as proud of what I hope to longterm accomplish.
I think that's one thing that I'm really working on.
And I also will kind of share it to anybody else
who's maybe diving into their next steps,
or a big endeavor for them is to appreciate the day to day
and be proud of those little moments,
and those little steps in the right direction
because it does go quick when you look back at least,
even if not in the moment.
Yeah.
We got to wrap this up in a couple of minutes,
but there's a couple more things I wanna touch on
before I release you to your life.
I think another reason why the video really worked
was that it wasn't just you telling your story.
You were like, "This this is what happened to me,
but what you need to understand is that
there's a systemic problem and that needs to change.
Nike needs to change.
Nike is too powerful."
And the investigation that had been launched
really had nothing to do with the way that you were treated
or this kind of toxic culture.
It was all about the doping thing, right?
And Nike ultimately is going to do what Nike needs to do
to protect its brand.
So it's going to basically give lip service to this,
sweep under the rug, whatever they can get away with,
and move on.
And you were the one at the outset calling for
a third party to conduct this investigation,
Okay, so they're gonna self police themselves here?
What does that actually mean?
Obviously, nothing's gonna happen.
So, my sense is that that didn't happen.
There is no third party investigating.
Is there any update?
I just wanted to know
what is the 2021 status update on what's happened there?
So I think first off there was an internal investigation,
and I only know this because one reporter was told that.
And I was reached out for comment
because I guess there was nothing released besides-
Nothing public,
there wasn't a public dossier or something,
"Here's what happened."
The only thing that was shared with this journalist,
Aaron Strout, from "Women's Running,"
was that they were gonna maybe
invest more in women and stuff like that, right?
Super vague, I can't even remember what it was.
And at the time I remember being asked for comment,
and I was like,
"Hey, any time any movement
is going towards empowering women, that's great."
Sure, and it's tricky and complicated
because you look at Serena Williams
and what they've done with her,
and it's unbelievable, right?
So it makes it, it's like, "Okay,"
and then you tell your story and I don't know what to think.
Yes, well, I think part of it is that we also have no idea
behind closed doors what was happening for anybody.
And it's a company made up of people, right?
And those individuals turn over.
People tried to protest within Nike.
There were like 100 people that protested right after-
Yeah, and people were threatened to be fired
if they walked near the Alberto Salazar building,
that's kind of scary.
Is it still called The Alberto Salazar building?
Yep.
The new Hayward Field, there's a Memorial to him.
There's a big picture at a stadium
that I'll probably have to run it multiple times
over the course of my career.
Oh my God, yeah.
And that was built after,
it was only recently finished, a couple months ago.
That's right, they just redid it.
And then they did a reboot.
So, I think for me, it's one of those things where,
as you know, you've seen him through the documentation
I've sent you for this
my own business that I'm trying to start.
I don't like using buzzwords,
and I try to avoid it at all costs.
So if I say like,
"I'm trying to empower women,"
that means nothing to me, right?
This is actually what I'm gonna do,
and I'm gonna outlay steps, A, B, C,
where we're gonna go,
how we're gonna support it.
And you know what, if I don't have an answer yet,
that's always okay.
But then say, I'm gonna have to lean on these partners,
and these experts, and take these next steps.
And so, I think the big maybe takeaways
if you're a multi-billion dollar organization,
is actually care,
and actually figure out like,
"Okay, if we're gonna do something, what are we gonna do?
And how are we gonna do it?"
And don't just keep coming out with ads that
even recently support
women who are pregnant and are athletes, right?
'Cause I watched that, and I think,
"You've never acknowledged how you treated Kara,
Alicea, Alison,"
there's never been any sort of like,
"Hey, we did wrong."
And I think I have always felt that
leaders are not people who do everything right.
Leaders are people
who are always trying to better themselves.
Always know they have places to learn,
and can acknowledge that they're going to fail some times.
And in those moments can step up and say,
"I'm sorry,
and this is how I'm going to change going forward."
Sure. They take responsibility.
I see it as, look you can try to whitewash this,
and put out a bunch of marketing campaigns,
and the truth is
the average public isn't paying attention to this.
No, of course, yeah.
So, it's not, is it?
So, how concerned are they really?
But ultimately, it seems to me
in their long-term growth interest
to really reckon with this,
the amount of goodwill that they would be able to engender
if the new CEO said, "I'm getting to the bottom of this.
I'm taking it super seriously,"
and they really did do a top to bottom revamp
on how they're dealing with all of these issues,
the amount of storytelling alone
that they could do out of that
would create a bulletproof brand going forward.
And they have the balance sheet
to be able to make that happen.
Yeah, I mean, I remember when the first kind of comments
from Nike came out after my piece,
first, I never thought they were gonna comment
'cause I never thought it was gonna be big enough,
but the fact that it was immediately
blaming and trying to undermine the story,
to me it was just horrifying.
But the thing is, so Alberto-
That backfired badly though.
Yes, I mean, Alberto is still,
I think is still kind of,
the USADA appeal has been,
I think it's complete at this point.
I'm not sure as of when the podcast release,
whether or not there'll be any sort of findings,
we're still waiting on the final SafeSport ruling about
whether this is an indefinite ban for him via SafeSport.
So there's still two different investigations
that are yet to be fully determined.
But the thing is that his whole legal pursuit with USADA
and with SafeSport is being backed by Nike.
And they've been very public
that they're supporting him in his appeals.
And I think that's one of those moments
where you're just like,
"How can you not just listen to my story,
but listen to Kara's,
and Amy Yoder Begley,
and all of these other athletes
who have come forward and said,
'This happened to them,'
and still try to shut them down."
And I think when you live in a world where
there's that amount of power,
and there's that much of a will
to take away an athlete's voice,
it makes me want to live in a world
where you're empowering those athletes
and giving them voice.
And that's really my goal,
is I want the sport to be better once I leave it.
I want athletes to be more empowered.
I want them to be protected.
I want them to be safe.
I want them to be healthy.
And I think when I was young,
I always wanted to be
the greatest professional athlete in the world.
And the truth is I still want that.
But I think my definition of greatness has changed.
And I realize that if I had won
all of the races I ever wanted to win,
but I never stood for anything,
that's not great.
To me that's going of lame.
And if I end my career having really changed the sport
in a positive way, that's greatness.
And so, that's what I strive for.
It's crazy how that works, right?
Because you would have suspected that
the way for you to have the biggest impact
is to go win a bunch of gold medals,
or set world records, or what have you.
And maybe that'll still happen.
Hopefully.
I'm interested in where you're running is right now.
But completely detached or irrespective of that
because of all of these things
you're now in a position to have
a real, permanent, meaningful, substantive impact
on the future of girls and women's athletics.
That never would have happened
had you not endured the things that you went through.
Yeah, and I think, the thing that's hard for me sometimes
is that the dream I had as a young athlete
of being a professional.
And I used to be a swimmer too.
So I used to keep that a little vague which way we'd go.
I know.
It cropped up here and there.
Exactly.
I know.
While you're running 5:47 miles in sixth grade.
Yeah, I was still swimming, that was my primary sport.
Swimmers don't know how to run.
So there's something weird there.
I see triathlon in your future.
Yeah. We'll see.
Okay.
But I think the hardest thing can sometimes be is that
the dream I had can now never happen, right?
Where the dream was to be a professional athlete,
and to train full time,
and to be the LeBron James,
the Serena Williams,
the insert any of the top athletes in the world,
the Usain Bolt, right.?
And the truth is even if I win the Olympics,
I can't be that person.
That dream was taken away from me
because I'm not a professional athlete on paper.
And the thing is,
it's been this really interesting reworking
of how do you let one dream die and let another one blossom?
And I think that's kind of what this last year and a half
has been for me is accepting I can do something different,
and still love it, and still be proud of it.
And that's been kind of an interesting, I would say journey,
of realizing that how a dream is lived
has to sometimes change.
Beautifully put.
I think that's a good place to put a pin on it
until next time.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you. That was really powerful.
I appreciate you being so open and honest with me
about all of that.
No, and thank you for giving me the space to cry,
to at times move my arms.
Are you kidding?
I love it when people,
it's been a long time since somebody cried on the podcast.
You might be the first person to cry in the new studio,
so you'll always have that.
I've christened it with my tears.
Yeah.
If I come to New York,
will you go running with me and Lindsay Crouse?
Can we go running together?
Oh my God, that'd be amazing.
You guys have to run real slow though,
slow down a lot.
Sounds great to me, I'll allow it.
That would be super fun.
And don't steal Alexi, Alexi is my BFF,
she's my neighbor now.
So just boundaries.
You're going over to her house right now, right?
Nearly guessed.
Just understand that I have dibs.
I think I've known her longer. I think I win.
That doesn't matter.
She lives here now.
I'm being protective and-
I know, I think long-term,
how do we get her to New York though?
I'm like putting the long game.
I like her down the street from me.
I don't want her to go to New York.
Maybe you do, put her on your board.
Yeah, true. Very true.
Awesome, well, I look forward to going running with you,
and talking more, so thanks.
How can people find out more about how to Atalanta?
You, you're easy to find on the internet,
but where do you wanna direct people?
Yep.
Social media is gonna always be the way to go.
My personal account is runmarycain,
and then Atalanta also has their own Instagram.
Cool, @Atalanta?
Yeah, NWC.
Atalanta,
I'm never gonna figure that out.
Atalanta NYC
Yeah.
Cool.
All right.
Thanks.
Peace plants running.
(bright upbeat music)